merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur d'Israël Mesdames et
Messieurs les
sénateur alors que des attaques
terroristes effroyables ont touché
l'État
d'Israël je veux au nom de mon
gouvernement dire toute ma solidarité et
mon soutien au peuple
israélien chaque jour nous découvrons de
nouvelles horreurs commises par les
terroristes du Hamas
chaque jour le bilan s'alourdit et je
veux redire solennellement avant toute
chose que rien jamais ne peut justifier
le
terrorisme aujourd'hui je pense aux
victimes et j'exprime la compassion de
la France à leur famille et à leurs
proches alors que le bilan vient une
nouvelle fois de
s'alourdir je veux avoir un mot
particulier pour nos 10 ressortissants
décédés et les 18 don dont nous sommes
sans
nouvell dans ce moment tragique je sais
l'émotion et l'angoisse qui saisissent
les Français vivants en Israël et les
franco-israéliens nous sommes avec eux
et nos services diplomatiques mettent
tout en œuvre pour les
accompagné mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le président de la République
l'a dit avec force nous sommes au côté
d'Israël pays allié de la France qui vit
un drame terrible je vous remercie
[Musique]